. Hey, hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Folge, setz dich erstmal hin, Flo und ihn. Ich kann das nicht sehen, wie du hier rum wackelst mit deinem Vorderfuß-Entlastungsschuh. Und Stefan Tietze. Und mir, Stefan Tietze. Du warst heute vor mir da, ich dachte, das kann nicht sein. Mit diesem Fuss. Ich dachte, ich habe Zeit. Ich habe mir gar nicht die Mühe gemacht, mich irgendwie zu beeilen. Weil ich habe mir dir vorgestellt, wie du damit rumläufst, mit diesem dicken Klotz am Bein. Deswegen dachte ich mir, ich brauche mich nicht beeilen. Aber dann warst du vor mir da, hast du es geschafft, vor mir herzuwackeln. So, erstmal vielen Dank an Maximilian für das fantastische Intro, dankeschön. Hätte ich ja jetzt gesagt, brauchst du mir jetzt nie so. Ja, es geht immer noch weiter, ich bin immer noch, mein Vorderfuss ist weiterhin entlastet, ich bin jetzt aber in Phase zwei, ich weiß nicht, ob du das kennst, wenn du irgendwas... Nee, ich war in meinem Leben noch nie in Phase zwei, das ist mein Ding, ich bleibe in Phase eins. Wenn du zum Beispiel irgendwie, keine Ahnung, du kriegst einen gebrochenen Arm, hast einen Gips und deine erste Woche, oh vorsichtig, vorsichtig, oh nein, oh vorsichtig, aber irgendwann gewöhnst du dich dran und fängst an, diesen Gipsarm zu ownen einfach und auf der Strasse checkst du Leute weg einfach, hackst damit deine Zwiebeln, schlägst damit aufs Schnitzel ein und genau so ist mein Leben jetzt auch so. Wie viele Obdachlose hast du getreten? Einige. Erste Woche Vorderfußentlastungsschuh, oh vorsichtig, Treppe, da kommt mir jemand entgegen, Vorsicht bitte, Vorsicht, ich nehme den Aufzug. So, aber Woche zwei und jetzt Woche drei, ich own das Ding, Alter, ich stolzier damit durch die Gegend, ich klumpe überall hin.
Woche drei, das ist ein fucking C.
Jetzt macht man mal keine, jetzt macht man mal keinen.
Jetzt erst einmal heute, ich war heute bei der Orthopäde nochmal, die schaut sich das an.
Die hat auch gesagt, Alter, das ist ein fucking C.
Warum kommen Sie hier ständig?
Alter.
Sie sind jetzt das dritte Mal diese Woche hier, warum sind Sie da?
Und die meint ja auch so, ja, drei Wochen jetzt, ne?
Ja, ist eigentlich geheilt, aber lass uns noch mal eine Woche mit Verband machen. Bitte was, wie ist es geheilt, aber lass uns noch mal eine Woche draufsetzen. Ja, das ist auch vage alles. Das ist alles ein bisschen vage. Ich finde auch Orthopäden vage. Die lernen dieses, ich will gar nicht wissen, wie deren Studium aussieht, aber dieses, allein, es gibt nichts Vageres als der Begriff Prellung, finde ich.
Ja, das stimmt, ja.
Es gibt nichts Schlimmeres als, ja, ist es jetzt schlimm oder nicht, es ist eine Prellung. Es ist eine Prellung. Es ist genau auf der Mitte zwischen Verletzung und nichts. Es gibt bestimmt auch diesen einen medizinischen Fachausdruck für, ich habe keine Ahnung, was es ist, aber damit andere Ärzte auch verstehen, ah, damit der Patient nicht verunsichert ist, halt irgendwie so Fraktur oder sowas,
wo er einfach sagt, ja, das ist eine eindeutige Fraktur, schreibt Fraktur und der andere Arzt weiss, ja, okay, man weiss es einfach nicht. Bestimmt gibt es solche Begriffe. Es ist wie wenn Eltern vor Kindern Englisch sprechen oder anfangen zu buchstabieren, weil Kinder nicht verunsichert werden sollen. Seine Mutter ist TOT. Okay, aber da hatten wir es ja letzte Woche mit diesem, dass man oft die Hälfte von irgendeinem Fakt weiss und dann nicht weiss, ob man den Fakt nennen soll oder nicht. Ich finde, es sollte ein Wort geben, das man einsetzt, das klar zeigt, ich weiss grob, worum es geht, mir fällt jetzt nur das konkrete Wort nicht ein. Also zum Beispiel, keine Ahnung, dein Computer ist langsam oder dann irgendwie, du hast zwei Sachen gleichzeitig offen auf deinem Computer und dann sagt er, oh warum ist es jetzt so langsam? Ja, du hast zwei Sachen gleichzeitig, das belastet halt, du weißt es nicht, CPU, RAM, keine Ahnung, irgendeiner dieser Begriffe halt. Der spezifische Begriff, aber du weißt zu viel, um diesen Satz nicht doch auszusprechen. Du weißt das, was essentiell ist. Zwei Programme gleichzeitig laufen lassen ist zu viel für den Harry halt. Ich möchte noch mal Smisma in den Raum werfen. Und da folge ich dir genau richtig, denn Smisma ist genau einfach dieses Wort. Smisma ist das ist ja lapidar, das ist dann auch egal, das ist so weggeschön. Vor allem, man kann ja auch sagen sowas wie Ding oder Dingstar, aber das ist mir zu un... Das zeigt, dass du gar keine Ahnung hast. Dann ist halt dieses Dingstar, das ist so ein Desinteresse, so ich will gar nicht wissen, was es genau ist, das belastet halt dieses Dingstar zu viel. Wohingegen, wenn du sagst Smisma, weiss der Zuhörer... Erstmal nicht, was er gemeint. Erstmal viele Fragezeichen. Lass uns mal fünf Jahre in die Zukunft sprechen, wenn unser Buch sich gut verkauft. Und Smisma zeigt dem Zuhörer aber, ah, er weiss gerade nicht CPU, RAM, Motherboard, eins dieser drei, aber er pendelt zwischen diesen drei und hat sich auf Smisma geeinigt. So, und er weiss es eigentlich. An anderen Tagen hätte er es gewusst. Ja, ich denke auch. Sowas bräuchte es vielleicht. Ich kenne mich da auch gar nicht aus. Ich habe früher manchmal so einen Computer zusammengebaut aus verschiedenen RAMs und CPUs und Smisma. Gedöns. Gedöns ist auch so, aber es hat die gleiche Wirkung wie Dings. Und ich habe alles vergessen darüber. Das sind auch diese Dinge, die man dann einfach vergisst mit Wasserkühlung und dann so Lüfter, die man draufsetzt, die hatten dann so LEDs und so.
Ich hatte immer so eine Phase, wo ich dann wirklich so Computer gebastelt habe, aber mittlerweile, ich weiß gar nicht mehr, ich kaufe mir so ein MacBook-Ding und dann habe ich das da. Ja, das ist ja so das Dumme an Wissen ist, dass wenn dir nur ein Teil fehlt, ist alles unbrauchbar. So wenn du nur ein Teil vom Computer nicht kennst, dann brauchst du gar nicht anfangen, ihn zusammenzubauen, weil du checkst es nicht. Und du kannst auch nicht gut über Dinge, also angenommen, wie wird in Deutschland ein Gesetz erlassen und du kennst eine Instanz nicht. Bundesrat fällt dir nicht. Eine Instanz kennst du nicht. Und dann ist alles andere, was du vielleicht perfekt erklären, wie die anderen Smilmars halt funktionieren, aber diese fehlt ja und das ist das ist ärgerlich deswegen habe ich mit wissen auch gebrochen irgendwie so ich habe die menschheit auch mit wissen gebrochen und ich habe ja auch in meinem journalismstudium ich werde auch nicht müde das zu erwähnen aber habe ich gelernt dass selbst die menschen von denen wir unser halbwissen haben dieses an dieser strohalm des Wissens, an den wir uns klammern, selbst die sind ja so wie wir und wissen nicht alles.
Und dann haben die da, dann habe ich so mit Leuten vom Monitor gesprochen, die dann da auch eine Sendung machen, die extrem für unseren Wissensstand verantwortlich ist.
Und selbst die, die recherchieren dann so in die Lücken hinein, so dann lassen Sie mal einen Satz hinter den Tisch fallen, weil Ihnen jetzt nicht mehr genau eingefallen ist, woher die diese Quelle hatten und so weiter. Oder die ruft, vergessen mal einen anzurufen extra, damit der Beitrag noch irgendwie Sinn ergibt, vergessen Sie dann hier mal die Gegenseite anzurufen, etc. Es ist ja auch oft so, du hast so einen Beitrag und die Deadline nähert sich und denkst dir, wenn ich diesen Fakt jetzt noch überprüfe, laufe ich Gefahr,
dass er nicht stimmt
und mein gesamter Beitrag zerschossen ist.
Deswegen, je
weniger ich recherchiere, desto einfacher
ist mein Job. Aber du wirst mir
wohl recht geben, dass es in einem Beitrag, wo es
um irgendeinen
Skandal, halt um Wissen
geht, was man vermitteln sollte,
dass es da nicht darum gehen sollte,
dass ich meinem Chef mit einer Deadline gefallen will. Oder wenn man, ich nehme auch so einen Kinderkanal, wo man Kindern Wissen beibringt und dann vergisst du einen Fakt oder so, weil der Chef blöd war am Dienstag und dann willst du den mit einem tollen Beitrag überraschen, der schon plötzlich Donnerstag fertig ist. Viel eher als gedacht. Aber dir ist scheißegal, dass du Kindern Wissen beibringst. Das ist auch schwierig.
Vor allem deswegen habe ich enorm grossen Respekt vor Leuten, die Sachbücher veröffentlichen, weil das ist ja dann erst mal fest. So und dann schreibst du da halt rein so ja Physik, die Protonen und die Quantonen und dann ist das Ding veröffentlicht und einer schreibt, du hast die Elektronen und Protonen verwechselt durch das gesamte Buch durch. Und ja, ah, fuck, ey. Ich finde Sachbuchautoren nicht cool, ich finde die einfach arrogant. Ja, super. Dass die meinen, weil die wollen genauso geliebt werden wie Leute, die so, weiß ich nicht, wie Ralf Rute im Endeffekt. Ja. Aber Ralf Rute hat erkannt, nee, nee. Fakten sind nicht seins. Fakten sind nicht seins und dann fängt er an zu malen. Und das denke ich mir auch dann, die Sachbuchautoren, die sind einfach noch, die halten noch an dieser Arroganz fest, irgendwie Wissen vermitteln zu können. Nein, aber Sachbuchautoren sind im Kern auch einfach nur Ralf Rote. So, das irgendwann macht man einfach diese Erfahrung. Ja, das habe ich mir nicht gefraut zu sagen. Du hast es ausgesprochen, ich habe es gedacht, aber nee, finde ich auch gut, da müssen wir immer die Wahrheit sagen. Ich hatte eine ganz schlimme Woche hinter mir, um ehrlich zu sein. Richtig schlimme Woche, meine N-Taste klemmt.
So, und erstmal, jetzt werden die meisten von euch sagen, pff, N, N, der Buchstabe N, wann kommt der mal vor, ihr lacht euch kaputt, N ist der, wenn eine Taste nicht klemmen sollte, dann Space oder N. Wann kommt der mal vor? Ihr lacht euch kaputt. N ist der, wenn eine Taste nicht klemmen sollte, dann Space oder N. Und ich dachte mir irgendwann, weil es ist doch gerade so eine Drehbuchschreibphase, wo man die ganze Zeit schreibt und der Fehler ist schlimm, weil entweder es kommt gar kein N oder dann ist man wütend irgendwann, haut aufs N, dann kommen direkt zwei Ns. Überall sind jetzt Rechtschreibfehler, die ganzen Skripte sind voller Rechtschreibfehler mit Ns oder viel zu vielen Ns oder viel zu wenig Ns. Ganz, ganz schlimm und es fällt ja auch nicht sofort auf. Und dann dachte ich mir, das kann doch nicht wahr sein, selektive Wahrnehmung, aha, das N kommt wahnsinnig häufig vor. Und dann habe ich aber mal geguckt und habe recherchiert, tief recherchiert, wie oft das N vorkommt. Wie hast du das hinbekommen? Ich habe Leute angerufen. Ich habe, wie gesagt, bei meinen Freunden beim Monitor angerufen. Ich finde es so gut, mein N-Taste ist kaputt. Häufigkeit von der Buchstabe nach M der Buchstabe ach M der Buchstabe ach, m, ach. Der Buchstabe ach, m. Was? Ach, m. Und Google auch so. Ist einfach nur hm-Frage-Sinn? Ich bin schon wieder auf der hm-Seite. Ich bin häufig auf der hm-Seite. Nochmal? So, aber jetzt machen wir deswegen die Top Ten. Ich habe nämlich die Statistik gefunden. Die Top Ten Buchstaben der deutschen Sprache. Ja, also auf Platz zehn und du rätst jetzt bitte, auf Platz zehn ist T, L, auf Platz zehn ist das L, 3,44 Prozent und dann kürzerer blauer Ball. Ganz kurz, wenn man diese zehn Buchstaben als Wort liest, ergibt das dann zufällig Hurensohnel? Nee, aber auch lustig, aber kommen wir gleich zu, wir brauchen noch ein paar. Aber ich bin schon ganz aufgeregt. Okay, auf der neun. U. Richtig! Yes! Ja! Auf Platz neun U, 4,35 Prozent und ein leicht grösserer blauer Ball. Das ist die Häufigkeitsball, die kann ich auch einfach weglassen. Auf Platz 8. Auf Platz 8 ist das... Ist ein Aussenseiter, hätte ich nicht da oben erwartet. Ist ein bisschen Underdog. Underdog. Da will ich es W nennen. Nee, ist das D. Ah, okay. Mit 5,08 %, aber deutlich häufiger als das U, hätte ich nicht gedacht. Auf Platz sieben, ein Buchstabe, das du gerade schon mal gesagt hast. Dann S. Ne, T. T ist sehr, sehr wichtig. 6,15 Prozent und ein grösserer blauer Balken. Platz sechs. Platz sechs, das kommt man schon langsam in die Vokalrichtung, deswegen würde ich sagen O. U hatten wir sogar schon. O würde ich sagen. Nein, O ist gar nicht in der Liste. Was? Das glaubt man überhaupt nicht. Kein O? Nee, nee, Platz sechs ist A dann schon. Aber Platz sechs A, es kommen noch fünf Buchstaben. Ja. Ich kenne gar nicht mehr Buchstaben. Platz fünf. Auch, oh Scheiss, hätte ich. Es kommt jetzt noch kein I. Ich hätte auch Platz zwanzig, den Buchstaben hätte ich auf Platz zwanzig getippt. Ich glaube, es kommt noch mal ein Konsonant. Ich sage... Und was für einer? Ich sage K. R. R, ja, stimmt. R, unglaublich wichtig. Ja, Protokoll. Aber auch, weil Wortendungen, glaube ich, da holt das R viel raus.
Ja, werben, ne?
Ja, hinten raus.
R greifen.
Ja.
Sterben.
Werfen.
Aber auch Angreifer, die ganzen männlichen Endungen.
Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Na ja, ja, ja.
Ja, ja.
Dann auf Platz vier.
Dann sag ich mal I.
Yes, I.
Ja, I.
7,5 Prozent.
Ja, also.
Auf Platz drei.
Kommt noch ein Konsonant jetzt? Ja. Das ist der häufigste Konsonant. Der häufigste Konsonant, nee, das ist nicht der häufigste Konsonant. Ja, wir brauchen wahrscheinlich noch das N, um deine Porn nicht vorwegzunehmen. Aber, ähm. Auf Platz drei, der häufigste Bstab Deutschlands, das, oh, warte mal, das wird spannend, das ist gerade sehr spannend oder sehr langweilig, ich kann es nicht einschätzen.
Dann gib mir das M, das S, ach, fuck S, 7,89%, ja, auf Platz eins kann man sich denken, das E, auf Platz 2 ist das N. Nein! Alter, das hätte ich nicht gedacht. Ich habe die Statistik aufgerufen, mit der festen Überzeugung, dass N mindestens auf Platz 3 ist. Und es war auf Platz 2. Es ist der zweithäufigste Buchstabe, mit 9,78 Prozent, sogar eindeutig auf Platz 2, 17,41 Prozent das E. Aber N, holy shit, das fällt einem erst auf, wenn das N klemmt. Das N klemmt, so heißt die Folge auch. Das N klemmt wohl. Nee, wirklich, das ist ganz, ganz schlimm, das wollte ich mal dringend ansprechen. Ja, tu das. Und kann aber auch daran liegen, dass das N ausgerechnet deswegen kaputt ist, weil es so häufig vorkommt, habe ich auch gedacht vielleicht. Aber wo ist das N überall drin? Schlangen, Plural viel, Plural, Pferden. Ja, aber auch alle Verben in der Grundform. Sowas wie Nennen, Nun, Den, Nashorn, diese ganzen. Ja, Ansage, Lang, auch bei N ist ja Langsam, Engel und so hast du immer mit drin. Gong, auch ein tolles Wort. Ja, also das N ist nicht zu unterschätzen. Unterschätzen wir das N nicht, meine Freunde. Jetzt musst du dir lauter Charakternamen ausdenken und die heißen dann alle Mike. Würde es auffallen, gibt es ja draußen ein Buch, das komplett ohne N geschrieben ist? Ich glaube, Charlie Kaufman hat mal irgendwann, ich glaube, being John Merkiewicz besitzt den Buchstaben S nicht. Aber ich glaube, es gibt Texte ohne E, also wo man sagt, A ist der Hörhör, habe ich gesehen, ich setze es mir aus Herausforderung, einen Text ohne E zu schreiben, das gibt es bestimmt. Aber es schimmert da bestimmt, ich glaube so Harry Potter Teil 5 oder so. Und J.K. Rowling so auf dem Sterbebett einfach so, übrigens, Harry Potter Teil 5, kein W. Und Dobby schwul! Alle sind schwul außer Dobby! Ciao! Nein! Tod. Also gut, aber komisch ein bisschen. Also, ich bin ja progressiv. Aber warum Dobby nicht? Sie ist tot. Ja, ach man, wahrscheinlich, aber das wäre immer eine interessante Challenge. Jetzt habe ich den Dreh raus, wie man Harry Potter Romane schreibt. Jetzt irgendwie Level zwei, next level, reimt sich. Oder von hinten und vorne kann man es lesen und es ist die gleiche Geschichte. Das ist ein großes Annerstag, Palindrom. Drohnen. Ganz kurz, eine Sache, die ich sagen wollte, bevor ich es vergesse, heute, also es gibt ja Comedy-Momente in Comedy-Shows, Sketch-Shows, Stand-Up. Aber, ich hätte mir gewollt, dass da noch ein paar andere, dass die Aufzählung nie endet. Ich hatte heute einen im echten Leben und es war wirklich geschrieben wie in einem Sketch und ich dachte er hat so. Hat ein Publikum gelacht? Ich habe wirklich im Kopf instinktiv den Lacher gehabt, weil dann bevor mein Fuss begutigt werden konnte, musste erst der vorige Verband abgenommen werden. Große Verbandsschere, ja, schnipp, schnipp, schnipp, ein Stück ab. Ist es die Bürgermeister, wir eröffnen Dinge, Schere? Das ist die riesige, ja. Es ist die eine große Schere der Stadt. Falls ihr euch gefragt habt, was mit denen passiert, nachdem der Bürgermeister spendet, ist immer wie ein Ritual an die Orthopädenstiftung, dann kommt der Cheforthopäde zum Hut, mit so einem Fuss. Aber mit einem lächerlich großen Hut. Und dann, hä, aber ist so eine grosse Schere, ne? Es ist schon eine grosse Schere, es ist diese Knickschere, die auch super geil ist, weil die auf einer Seite stumpf ist und dann reißt sie so ab. So, und dann konnte die Orthopädin ja nicht an dem Verband so wirklich ziehen, weil dann der Zeh Gefahr läuft, abzubrechen. Und sie hat dann immer so kleine Stücke abgeschnitten und immer so vorsichtig und vorsichtig. Und sie meinte dann auch so, ja, ich kann ja jetzt hier nicht so fest ziehen, sonst, ne, das darf mir wirklich nie wieder passieren. Blick zur Assistentin, die nickt Kreisblende um die Assistentin. Und ich dachte mir, das ist nicht dein Ernst. Nein. Das ist der beste Moment aller Zeiten.
Wirklich, vor allem es war so ein lockeres Schnippschnipp und dann haha, ja, ich muss ja kleine Stücke, weil... Und dann Ernst, das darf mir nie wieder passieren. Was? Und ich dachte mir, was? Hatte jemand den Zeh gebrochen, der in der Heilung war, weil sie so hart gerissen, hat die den Zeh abgerissen? Das darf mir nie wieder, aber auch diese Reue, die da mitschwingt, dieses, ich glaube, sie kann auch jeden Abend, hasst sie sich dafür. Aber hat die das ernst gemeint oder war das ein Scherz? Also wie gesagt, ich glaube nicht, dass die eine ist, die die Scherze macht. Weil sie Orthopäde ist. Also die ist knallhart und wirklich so ein Bärenfell irgendwie über dem Plakat, wo man so die Röntgenaufnahmen sieht. Also die ist wirklich hart. Aber auch wirklich so, ich glaube, als Ärztin und Arzt das Erste, was man lernt, ist, strahl Kompetenz aus, bitte. Ich glaube, sieben Jahre des Medizinstudiums sind, wie strahl ich Kompetenz aus. Das ist die halbe Miete. Wenn dir jemand Kompetenz sagt, ja, nimm das, mach das, in zwei Wochen sehen wir uns wieder, bist du schon so gut wie geheilt, weil der Rest ist placebo, dein Körper übernimmt den Rest, wenn du denkst, okay, krass, ich wurde geheilt. Und deswegen fand ich es so erstaunlich, dass, weil sowas hört man selten, dass Ärzte zweifeln an sich selbst. So und dann so, scheiße, ich hoffe, ich schaffe das jetzt. Ich hoffe, ich schaffe das. Das ist meine erste OP. Nie, aber bei der wirklich, das darf mir echt nicht nochmal passieren, nie wieder passieren. Aber auch diese, mir gefällt, wie unbedrängt sie ja auch ist, also ich muss es ja nicht sagen. Ja, überhaupt nicht. Aber so als. Ist nicht so, dass du sie in so einer Einbahnstraße manövriert hast. Irgendwie so, sie schneidet diesen Verband auf und dann, ja, ich darf jetzt nicht festziehen. Und dann kam alles wieder, kamen die Bilder hoch. Hat kurz gezuckt und dann PTSD. Aber auch die Assistentin mit so einem ernsten Blick und so einem Nicken einfach. Sie ist eigentlich der Schlüssel. Richtig. Sie hat es eigentlich zum Comedy-Moment gemacht. Genau. Sie ist der Anspielpartner. Genau, du brauchst immer den dritten, der dann, oh ja, den brauchst du immer. Wo du dann auch in diese toten Augen gucken kannst und merkst, und in Augen quasi diesen Horror. Ja, oder dann so einen Blick nach draußen in den Garten, wo so ein Haufen Erde im Garten ist und dann so Donner und irgendwas. Hier liegt C. Ja, also das war ein fantastischer Moment heute. Aber war sie unverhältnismässig froh über das Gelingen danach?
Ja, das schon, aber ich glaube, darin spielte auch so dieses, ja, es ist schon geheilt, aber zur Sicherheit lieber nochmal eine Woche. Und das war dann auch so, ja, okay, gut, die hat was aufzuarbeiten, die will keinen Fehler machen, auf gar keinen Fall. Die überkompensiert jetzt mit, also die will deinen Vorderfuß erstmal nicht mehr belasten. Und habe ich letztendlich erzählt, weil ich noch was, weil ich nicht weiß, ob ich das Versprechen einlöse. Und zwar, die hat mir dann noch Medikamente verschrieben. Beschleunigte Heilung und Schwellung gegen Schwellung und für beschleunigte Heilung. Hol mir diese Medikamente, bin zu Hause, Homöopathie. Nein. So. Und jetzt dachte ich und jetzt plane ich fest, an meinem letzten Termin mit ihr zu sagen, nochmal, haben sie eigentlich einen kompletten Schaden? Erstmal, sie laufen dir rum und reissen dir die Zehen ab. Zweitens. Sie haben eine Halskette mit Zehen dran. Ja, meinst du, ich sehe das nicht. Zweitens, Homöopathie. Das Problem, das einzige Problem. Da sieht man N drin. Eben. Das Wort kann ich nicht ernst nehmen. Das Problem ist viel zu lang dafür, dass es kein N drin ist, finde ich. Und ich habe mir überlegt, wie mache ich das? Wie konfrontiert man so einen Arzt? Mich würde wirklich ernsthaft interessieren, ob die da selber dran glaubt, ob die es als Placebo verschreibt, ob das so ein finanzielles Ding ist irgendwie, die zahlen mehr und ich brauche keine Medikamente, aber sie nimmt halt, also ich will ja nichts unterstellen, aber man kann ja, dass Ärzte Geld verdienen ist ja kein Geheimnis und dass man da vielleicht hier und da mal Medikamente verschreibt, die vielleicht mehr Geld bringen als andere, keine Ahnung, ich habe jetzt eben gar nichts. Deswegen interessiert mich das. Und ich weiß nicht genau, wie diese Konfrontation aussehen soll. Und mein Hauptbedenkenpunkt ist, dass ich über das Wort Homöopathie stolper. Es ist wie ein Bäcker in der Schlange. Und man sagt ja auch ungern längere Brötchennamen. Genau. Man sagt ja, und das Lächerliche ist ja, die heißen ja auch alle mittlerweile nicht mehr wie das, was sie sind. Ja, das sind Gesundbrunnen und das Kernchen. Ja, Knusper-Sandwich. Und man sagt, das ist ein Rührei-Scherbatter. Das ist auch nicht einfacher auszusprechen unbedingt, aber das ist auch manchmal albern. Und manchmal nämlich nicht das, was ich am liebsten mag. Einfacher, weil das einen albernen Namen hat. Wenn du überlegst, ob du jetzt den Fitnessfreak bestellst oder eine Kornsemmel, dann ist meine Entscheidung schon gefallen. Ja, ich will das Schlemmermäulchen-Taschen-Täschchen-Täschchen-Zweig. Ich hätte gerne den Käsetraum. Nee, hätten sie nicht. Und dann, deswegen so... Man stolpert drüber. Man stolpert drüber, weil du verlierst in der Sekunde, in der du dich versprichst, sämtliche Kompetenz, Autorität, die ich eh nicht habe, aber das bisschen, was ich habe vielleicht als informierter Patient, verliere ich in dem Moment, in dem ich Homöopathie ... Parteiso. Parteiso? Ich habe Ihnen kein Homöopathiso verschrieben. Das ist aber auch ein Wort, was da, ich glaube, da steckt auch die Homöopathie-Lobby hinter, damit man es nicht kritisiert offen, weil deswegen haben die diese Ö-O-Konstruktion. Diese Kombi-Ö-O, das ist einzigartig in der deutschen Sprache.
Holy shit, da ist alles falsch. Woher kommt das, Homöopathie, so irgendwie Griechisch oder sowas?
Keine Ahnung, das weiß ich nicht.
Das klingt so, ja, das ist alles so, das sagt man nicht so gern. Aber ich verstehe diese Angst gut, ich finde es auch wirklich interessant. Vor allem, weil Orthopäden und Homöopathie kriege ich in meinem Kopf auch nicht so richtig zusammen. Weil das eine ist sehr plastisch, Knochen brechen, Gips rum, fertig. Es wirkt wie eine der pragmatischsten Heilkünste. Es sind so die Zementmischer der Medizinindustrie.
Es sind die Brachialen. Ich finde, das sind die Robusten. Und das andere wirkt sowieso Hexen, Naturheilkunde. Ja, und es gibt ja immer so diesen Spruch, den man überall liest, Zahnärzte sind keine Ärzte. So, weil Zahnärzte haben anscheinend nicht Medizin studiert, im klassischen Sinne, das, was man so als das super harte Medizinstudium kennt, sondern Zahnmedizin ist wie Tiermedizin so ein bisschen hinterhergewacht. Mach den mal, der hat den Gebiss, mach mal rum. Der Kindertisch ist der Medizin. Ich weiß aber nicht, wie es bei Orthopäden ist. Ob die auch Medizin studiert haben, deswegen keine Ahnung. Ich weiß nicht, wie viel Respekt ich vor denen haben soll. Doch, doch, die haben schon medizinische Hände. Die haben schon alles, die sind all in. Orthopäden sind voll, all in. Okay, ja okay. Orthopäden sind auch immer voll. Das ist quasi synonym für lange Warten in meinem Kopf auch. Ja, weil die Patienten alle so langsam sind. Das ist halt so, die humpeln da immer so durch die Gänge. und vor allem beim Orthopäden, da gibt es ja das Wartezimmer und dann einen ganz langen, dünnen Gang zu den Behandlungsräumen. Und das ist wirklich wie so ein Super Mario Level, wo in so immer fünf Zentimeter Abständen so eine Feuerkugel kommt. Und genau so ist diese Orthopädie auch, weil immer da kommt irgendwie so ein alter Mann mit einer Krücke, eine Frau mit so einem Rollstuhl. Und es ist wirklich, du musst dann in die anderen Räume rein und immer so da durch wie so ein Frogger-Spiel, weil da einfach ein unähnlicher Schwarm an irgendwie gebrochenen Menschen dir entgegenkommen. Das ist ganz, ganz merkwürdig. Was ist denn die Definition von Orthopädie eigentlich? Fussigkeit. Alles, was sich mit der Fussigkeit beschäftigt, ist Orthopädie. Fussigkeit. Das Fusstum. Aber auch Knochentum.
Auch, doch, doch, Rückentum.
Ja, aber Fuss und Rücken ist ja eine Suppe.
Ja, am Ende ist alles Körper,
kann man auch sagen.
Ich weiß wirklich nicht, wo hört Fuss auf,
wo fängt Rücken an.
Es ist ja immer so dieses Ding, du sitzt im Wartezimmer
jemandem gegenüber und denkst dir,
der sieht gesünder aus.
Was hat er? Der sieht gesünder aus,
der hat keinen Verband, der hat keine dumme Beule irgendwo.
und er denkt, so dieses Ding, du sitzt im Wartezimmer jemandem gegenüber und denkst dir, der sieht gesünder aus. Was hat er? Der sieht gesünder aus, der hat keinen Verband, der hat keine dumme Beule irgendwo. Und er guckt dich auch an, fragt sich, was hast du? Und ich wackele mit meinem Vorderfußentlastung. Weisst du, was man bräuchte? Kennst du noch Wer bin ich? Dieses Spiel, wo jeder quasi ganz viele Köpfe vor sich hat und dann stellst du Fragen, hat er eine Brille auf, jeder hat eine eigene Karte und dann sagst du, nee, keine Brille, dann klappst du alle um, die eine Brille haben. Das wäre geil im Wartezimmer mit Krankheiten. Und ich weiss, was du hast und alle Krankheiten sind auf diesem Feld und ich frage, Genitalbereich, wir sind im Orthopäden also wahrscheinlich, was mit Knochen. Richtig.
Okay, Krebs weg, Leukämie, Krebs weg, alles weg, sehr viel weg, ist ein sehr großes Feld auch. Du hast nur noch so zwei, Knochen geschmolzen oder Beinbruch. Stehen Sie mal auf. War es heiß, wo Sie waren. Und dann sß ich dem gegenüber und ich denke mir, der sieht gesund aus. Und dann hieß es, Herr Müller bitte, und er steht auf mit einem, ah, okay, got it, got it. Vielleicht hat er das extra gemacht, um seine Daseinsberechtigung, einfach um zu sagen, ich gehöre hierhin. Ich habe beim, also es ist der schlechteste Ort, um an Impostal-Syndrom zu leiden, aber immer wenn ich mit dem Arzt bin, habe ich das Gefühl, dass die Krankheit, wegen der ich da bin, es nicht wert ist, gerade einen Arzttermin nötig zu machen. Absolut. Und deswegen sitze ich da immer und hoffe immer, dass das Symptom schlimmer wird gerade. Ich hoffe inständig, dass es gerade noch schlimmer wird.
Warum habe ich jetzt die Schmerzen nicht mehr?
Und dann bewege ich den Arm und denke mir, es war doch eben noch viel schlimmer. Das ist doch kein Grund, da bin ich mir kurz darauf, zu gehen, weil ich mir denke, ja, der Arm hat sich geheilt. Ich habe immer das Gefühl, ich bin es nicht wert, gerade untersucht zu werden, die Zeit in Anspruch zu nehmen. Ich habe zum Beispiel auch Leuten erzählt, dass ich mir ein Zeh gebrochen habe und dann barfuß ins Krankenhaus gefahren bin und die so, na Alter, das kannst du nicht machen, da musst du einen Krankenwagen rufen. Was? Und ich dachte mir, ich würde im Leben keinen Krankenwagen rufen, weil ich mir einen Zeh gebrochen habe. Einen Krankenwagen rufen? Ja, weil das, na ja, technisch gesehen bist du dann nicht mehr mobil, wenn du deinen Fuß verletzt hast. Ich bin auch so nicht mobil. Ey, bitte. Ich dachte mir wirklich, also bis ich sagen würde, mir geht es schlecht genug um Krankenwagen zu holen, da muss ich wirklich schon beide Arme verloren haben. Ein Arm verloren! Ich würde sagen, packst dein Eis, fährst ins Krankenhaus, car to go. Wirklich, wie gesagt, kein Ding. Aber das ist wahrscheinlich auch so dieses Imposter-Syndrom-Ding, dass du dir denkst, das ist im Ansatz nicht schlimm genug. Wahrscheinlich rufen Leute in den Krankenwagen völlig trivialen Scheiß, irgendwie Pizza ist runtergefallen, irgendwie mir auf dem Fuss, oh, ein bisschen heiß oder irgendwie sowas, rufen den Krankenwagen an. Knochen geschmolzen, zack, schon passiert. Dann ist es beim Arzt und es ist jemand gegenüber, der sich fragt, was hat er? Zu lange im Solarium, ich war jetzt 20 Sekunden zu lange im Solarium, vielleicht sind meine Knochen geschmolzen, ich rufe mal jemanden Krankenwagen an, never ever.
Und da habe ich mir auch gedacht, ich war überhaupt schon schüchtern, überhaupt in die Orthopädie zu geben, weil ich dachte, Entschuldigung, ich habe ein, ich habe mir zwei Zehen gebrochen, an beiden Füssen kriege ich noch einen Termin. Ich schieße an der Tür und hau mit dem Fuss in die Tür.
Krack!
Können Sie noch einmal doll zu... Wir müssen ganz kurz eine Pause machen, weil wir kurz los müssen Fotos machen.
Dann kommen wir ganz schnell zurück und machen den zweiten Teil dieser fantastischen Folge. Und wir heben kurz ab für eine Pause. Wir sind wieder gelandet. Mittlerweile ist es drei Uhr nachts. Es hat ein bisschen länger gedauert. Ich glaube, so spät haben wir noch nie aufgenommen, oder? Oh, es kann sein. Doch, ich glaube, wir haben einmal im Hotel aufgenommen. Das war lange her. Hast du ein gutes Gedächtnis eigentlich? Nee, ganz schlechtes Gedächtnis. Ich habe so eine Radioreportage gehört über Leute, die vergessen nichts. Es gibt manche Leute, die vergessen einfach gar nichts. Aber ist es nicht unglaublich ungesund? Es ist, na ja, ungesund. Nee, weil du auch, ist ja auch gut, Dinge zu vergessen. Total. Die dich traumatisiert haben, etc. Und die meinte dann auch so, ja, keine Ahnung, irgendwie Exfreund hat Schluss mit ihr gemacht und normalerweise dauert es halt so ein paar Monate, bis man drüber weg ist und für sie halt nie, weil sie kann das alles nicht vergessen. Auch so Trauer, wenn würde sterben und so. Weißt du, was ich letztens vergessen, weil das Tolle am Vergessen ist ja, dass du Dinge neu finden kannst. So, du kennst etwas schon und du vergisst es und dann findest du es neu. Mir geht es halt so, ich gucke jedes Jahr Ocean's Eleven, Days in Confused, Filme, die ich vergessen habe. Ja. Jedes Jahr aber auch. Und weißt du, was ich vergessen habe und heute neu entdeckt habe? Toast. Obstsalat. Obstsalat hatte ich mega lang vergessen, war mega lang raus. Und heute dachte ich mir so, ah, welches Obst, Banane, Grapefruit, Kiwi, alle schön zusammen in eine Schüssel. Schön Obstsalat. Und ich weiß nicht, aber gibt es... Ab wie vielen Zutaten ist Salat eigentlich? Ja, ich würde sagen, schon ab zwei eigentlich. Aber ist denn... Ich glaube, dass die Konsistenz des Zutaten auch wichtig ist. Also Dressing macht ja auch einen Salat. Also ich glaube, Blattsalat, normaler Kopfsalat, Eisbergsalat zum Beispiel aber auch und ein Dressing ist schon Salat. Ja, aber gibt es ein Dressing für einen Obstsalat? Weil ich habe da mal geguckt, man kann natürlich so ein bisschen Honig oder Zucker oder sowas in der Richtung. Aber vor allem, ich habe mich wieder masslos überschätzt. Ich glaube, ich hatte am Ende irgendwie so sieben Kilo Obstsalat oder so, weil ich habe das Obst gekauft. Was war dein Obst? Mein Obst war, ich dachte mir, Äpfel. Also, ich habe daran gedacht, was Ricky Gervais gesagt hat. Ricky Gervais wurde gefragt, warum ist The Office so verdammt gut? Und er hat gesagt, weil wir ... Erstens, weil ich Genie bin, zweitens, als wir die Serie gemacht haben, haben wir uns nicht so sehr überlegt, was wollen wir machen, als wir haben uns überlegt, was wollen wir gerade nicht machen. Also wir haben es sozusagen übers Negativ definiert. Wir, was soll unsere Komödie-Serie nicht sein. Okay, da hast du eine Liste gemacht mit jedem, allem Obst, das du nicht haben wolltest in dem Salat. Und ich dachte mir, was, woran denkt man normalerweise als erstes, wenn man Obstsalat denkt? Banane. Und deswegen habe ich mir gedacht, nee, ich lasse die Banane mal genau raus und schau, geht's auch ohne Banane? Ja, das ist wie wenn, genau, ein Autor schreibt ein Buch und sagt, geht's auch ohne N. Wenn ich es auch ohne N kann, dann kann ich es wirklich. Bis vor einer Woche hätte ich gedacht, easy, geht in Obstsalat ohne Banane. Bis vor einer Woche hättest du gedacht, ist doch einfach. Ja, geht in Obstsalat ohne Bahan, äh, Bahal, Bäh, B, geht denn Obstsalat ohne Bahi. Und deswegen habe ich die Banane weggelassen, deswegen wurde es am Ende Apfel, Orange, Birne, Himbeeren. Gut, du hast alles andere genommen. Also du hast Ricky Gervais nicht, also demnach wäre The Office eine Sache, die wir nicht wollen und Rest halt, was wir wollen. Das reicht schon, du musstest, du dichst negativ. Und vor allem dann habe ich mir eine Schüssel rausgeholt und alle Schüsseln bei mir sind gleich gross. Ich habe eine Schüssel rausgeholt und dachte mir, okay, die reicht für den Obstsalat. Am Ende hatte ich dreimal diese Schüssel, dreimal, weil es viel zu viel war, es ist dieses Spaghetti-Problem. Machst alles klein und am Ende hatte ich so wie so ein Schlagzeug, wie so ein Vitaminschlagzeug vor mir stehen, so drei verschiedene Schüsseln, wo ich dann auch immer so im Takt rausgegessen habe. Es hat dann geschmeckt. Ich habe einen Tipp für euch, ich bin ja gerade, ich versuche mich mit Ernährung auseinanderzusetzen, Sport, genau, und ein tolles Frühstück, ein super kalorienarmes, aber tolles, tolles leckeres Frühstück, weil darum geht es ja. Weil ich habe auch gemerkt, also mir ist wichtig, auch wenn man gerade in Phasen ist, wo man irgendwie auf seine Ernährung achten und abnehmen will oder so, ist auch wichtig, dass du da eine gute Zeit hast und nicht einfach nur leidest darunter, dass du dir gerade deinem Körper Dinge vorenthältst. Und deswegen ist da aber auch wichtig, gut drauf zu sein, also auch leckere Gerichte zu machen. Beispiel morgens ganz einfach, Mandelmilch, Haferflocken, ganze Haferflocken und eine Banane. Eine Banane, ein bisschen Haferflocken und Mandelmilch. Das ist dein Geheimt für ein schmackhaftes Frühstück, Haferflocken. Du, ich weiß, aber nach ein paar Monaten Hardcore-Diät ist das wie eine Neuentdeckung, wie ein Gefühl des Neugeborenwerdens. Ich fand das toll. Ich habe tatsächlich bei meinem Einzug, weil eine neue Wohnung ist ein neues Leben, und ich dachte mir, jetzt ernährst du dich mal gesund und habe mir wirklich eine Packung Hoverflocken gekauft. Und die steht heute noch ungeöffnet genau so bei mir im Regal als Wahrzeichen für, mach dir nichts vor, am Ende werden es die Frosties. Wenn du die aufmachst, dann, was passiert dann, kommt ein Fledermaus rausgeflohen. Wahrscheinlich, er hat sich irgendwas drin eingenistet oder es ist einfach nur so ein Zettel drin, siehste? Und du so, was, hä, hä, hä, was, guckt sich so um und dann steht ein anderer Mensch hinter dir, Ihr seid auch, siehste, wie sind Sie hier reingekommen? Es wird immer absurder.
Oder war es aus seiner Hosentasche? Guckt sich so um, dann steht ein anderer Mensch hinter dir, der sagt auch, siehste, wie sind sie reingekommen und es wird immer absurder.
Oder was aus seiner Hosentasche gibt dir, ein kleiner Zettel. Siehste, Fragezeichen.
Dann sagt er, hier, schau mal aus dem Fenster, was steht denn da im Himmel?
Dann kommt so ein Flugzeug vorbei, wo dann diesen Banner hinterher tragen, siehste.
Und ist der Pilot gerade aus dem Cockett besprungen, mit einem großen Fallschirm auf? auf dem steht, siehste, und kommt mir nicht genau auf dich zugeflogen gerade, rabatz ins Fenster rein und sagt dir, siehste, Moment, holt er gerade was aus seiner Hosentasche, ist das ein Zettel, erreicht es dir durch die zerschmetterte Fenster, Moment, wenn man sich das ausdenkt hier alle schon, warum dann zweimal den gleichen Trick, wenn man sich die Mühe macht, jemanden durch den Himmel fliegen zu lassen, mit einem Fallschirm, warum macht der denn auch den Hosentrick? Moment, ich mach den Zettel mal auf. Was steht da drauf? Was ist denn hinter deinem Ohr? Ich gucke hinter meinem Ohr. Siehste? Siehste. Wahrscheinlich, kann gut sein, oder es ist einfach ein schmackhaftes, nahrhaftes Frühstück. Aber ich gebe zu, ich mag die Konsistenz von Haferflocken. Ich mag es. Weil dieses matschige, stampfige, schlonzige, ich mag es, wenn Essen so ein gewisses Gewicht hat. Eine meiner kulinarisch erfüllendsten Szenen sind irgendwie, keine Ahnung, bei so einem Army Bootcamp oder sowas. Und dann alle müssen durch den Schlamm. Und dann stehen sie alle in der Cafeteria mit ihren Tellern und dann hast du so diese übel gelaunte Cafeteria-Kraft, die einmal diesen schweren Schöpflöffel so batz. Diese weisse Masse. Ja, aber einfach mit so einem, du weißt, es hat ein Gewicht, so batz und die ganze Küche vibriert und du hast einmal so diesen Fladen einfach auf dem Teller. Das gab es auch immer und es wurde immer als ekliges Kantinenessen gezeigt in Comics oder bei Disney-Große Pause oder so gab es das auch immer. Ich Ich dachte immer, hm, ich gehe mal probieren. Um ganz, ich finde immer, Zeichentrick-Essen ist so lecker. Das hat mir schon mal das Thema, aber ich finde auch, das Brot, dieses Brot, dieses braune, es gibt nichts leckereres als 2D-Brot, also dieses schlecht gemalte 2D, zweiben ja einfach basic dunkelbraun oval und dann dieses hellbraune diese drei schlitzel diese hellblau braun drei schlitzel ich fand auch bei asterix immer wildschwein so lecker selbst die hinkelsteine hätte ich angebissen vor allem haben die dieses große festessen am ende der folge und ich bin immer hungrig ins bett, weil ich mir immer dachte, so ein Wildschwein. Ja, vor allem, wenn du Chicken Wings bei KFC isst, da hast du Zeug dabei, was du nicht mitessen würdest normalerweise. Aber es ist halt so, es kommt auch dieses Rohe durch, weil du auch diesen Knochen in der Hand hast und vom Knochen abnagst, da scheißt du drauf. Und dann ist auch sehr viel Gewürz dran und du schmeckst nicht genau, was du da alles isst. Aber das Geile ist, bei diesem Asterix, diese Hähnchenkolony, die die auch essen, da ist ja nichts Schlechtes dran. Das ist nur, kann ich essen und Knochen. Weißt du? Da ist halt nicht, da gibt es keine Knorpel. Genau. Zwei D ist einfach eine bessere Welt. Und wenn es aufgeregessen ist, dann ist es auch ein blitzblanker Knochen, der direkt für Idefix übrig ist. Und es ist die perfekte Nahrungskette. Es ist für alle gesorgt.
Es ist kein Fett dran. Und natürlich, also für die Kenner Chihiros Reise ins Zauberland natürlich, die Eröffnungsszene mit dem ganz vielen Essen. Grossartig, grossartig. Ja, grossartig. Schaut es euch an, das ist ganz fantastisch. Es gibt auch einen Instagram-Account Simpsons Cuisine, wo alle Essensgerichte aus den Simpsons gepostet werden. Das ist supergeil.
Halt auch immer mit dem Text, der dazu gesprochen wird.
Es ist super lustig, es sind immer gute Gags, es sind immer gute Gags. Es ist immer das Foto von dem Simpsons Cuisine. Aber halt wie die in der Serie sind, ist es grossartig. Es gibt so viele gute Simpsons Instagram-Accounts auch, es ist fantastisch. Scenic Simpsons, so viele gute Sachen. Bitte? Scenic Simpsons gibt es auch, Simpsons Cuisine. Scenic Simpsons sind einfach ästhetisch ansprechende Frames aus Simpsons Episoden. Das kann alles mögliche sein. Das ist richtig toll. Das ist die einzige Prämisse. Ich mag es, dass so, wenn so verschiedene Welten aufeinander prallen. So Instagram, so dieses moderne, frische, hippe, coole, ultra ästhetisch, super kommerzielle, aber dann so was heimelig wohliges wie die Simpsons, das aber auf eine ganz besondere Art irgendwie eine Synthese findet.
Comedy ist ja auch oft, muss man sagen, die Synthese aus zwei sich scheinbar abstossenden Welten.
Fischhochzeit.
Wie?
Fische, die heiraten.
Das ist lustig.
Achso, wie viele Gags fallen hier ein? Achtung, zwei Delfine heiraten, Sketch, Fischhochzeit, Shoot, was Blumenmädchen, was streut das Blumenmädchen? Sehsterne. Was ist der Ring? Äh, Muräne. Baby Muräne. Wer ist der Pfarrer? Pinguin. Krabbe. Guck mal, schon, der Scant schreibt sich von alleine. Ja, kein Problem. Der Blumenstrauss jemanden wirft, das war's. Ja, Koralle. Das ist SpongeBob im Grunde. Aber so ist vielleicht SpongeBob entstanden. Wir dachten ja auch gerade Queer Eye, aber halt im Mittelalter, 16. Jahrhundert. Und ist eigentlich ein gutes Sketchreich. Wenn wir gute Arbeit noch hätten, würden wir Queer Eye im 16. Jahrhundert machen. Ja, Queer Eye kannst du in ganz vielen verschiedenen Situationen machen. Das finde ich auch lustig. Die kannst du so zum Schmied gehen. Ja. Also die Ritterüstung, nee, das kannst du so nicht anziehen. Das kann man so gar nicht anziehen. Null, das passt nicht zusammen. Silber zu Silber. Oder dann so Queer-Ei-Drittes Reich. Wir sind völlig zufrieden, hier ist alles perfekt, macht's gut, ciao! Mega! War das der Nazi oder der Schwule jetzt? Der Schwule, der Exzertiv spricht. Ach so, jemand weiß es nicht genau. Deine Imitationen sind sehr unpräzise geworden, Stefan. Nee, die sind einfach immer noch sehr schlecht und die werden auch nicht besser.
Mein österreichischer Akzent wird ein bisschen besser, kann ich jetzt nicht nachmachen, oder Dialekt, man weiss ja auch nicht genau, ob es eine andere Sprache oder nicht.
Ich habe das Gefühl, es wird ein bisschen besser, alle anderen Impressions ist weiterhin nicht mein Forte.
Wollen wir ganz kurz zu das Podcast UFO Feedback gehen?
Das Podcast UFO Feedback.
Back, back, back, back. Oh, da war ein Feedback. Ja, wir haben, wir wurden belehrt, wie es so häufig ist im Internet, und zwar haben wir einige Fehler gemacht in Nein, man darf keine Soldatenuniform tragen, wenn man kein Soldat ist. Ja, Soldaten haben Ausweise, Kasernenausweise, mit denen sie sich ausweisen können. Nein, wir dürfen die Rollladen nicht mehr runter machen, wenn wir aus dem Haus gehen, weil es Einbrecher anlockt, die gucken danach. Obwohl ich mir dachte, ich wohne im dritten Stock, ist das wirklich so ein Thema, ist da jemand wie so ein Enterhaken? Aber schützt nicht eine Rollladen vor Einbrechern, weil wie, also ich kann mir vorstellen, wie man durch ein Fenster kommt, ja, so der klassische Stein oder dieses kreisrunde Schneidwerkzeug. Du kannst einfach hochschieben, Alter. Nein! Wenn du es mit deinem Stümmelärmchen hochziehen kannst an dieser Schnur, kannst du es einfach von außen auch hochschieben. Ja, aber das ist doch super laut. Das ist glaube ich das Einzige daran. Deswegen habe ich so Glöckchen an meinen Rollladen. Die Rollladen sind wirklich wahnsinnig laut. Und deswegen glaube ich, ist es schon sicher. Also ich wurde belehrt, ich darf meine Rollladen nicht zumachen, wenn ich das Haus verlasse. Vor allem, ich denke immer so, ich glaube, der Grund, warum bei mir nicht eingebrochen wird, ist nicht, dass Leute denken, ich bin konstant zu Hause, sondern dass vielleicht niemand bei mir einbrechen will. Also ich weiß nicht, in welcher Welt man lebt, in der man immer davon ausgeht, sobald man Einbrecher die Gelegenheit gibt, wird man sofort ausgeraubt. Aber es ist vielleicht auch ein lokales Ding, vielleicht, keine Ahnung, ich habe noch nie davon mitbekommen, dass jemand ausgeraubt wurde. Ich weiß nicht, mir wurde gesagt, mit seinem Fahrrad bin ich so ein bisschen traumatisiert, weil ich denke, das habe ich seitdem nicht mehr rausgestellt, weil es ja geklaut wurde, wurde dann ja wiedergefunden. Mittlerweile habe ich es wieder. Ja gut, aber das ist ja außen so, das ist ja nicht. Ja, aber war sofort weg. Ich habe das halt, der Typ, der Fahrradverkäufer hat es gesagt, das ist ein sehr auffälliges Brennrad, das wird geklaut. Ich habe gesagt, ja, nein, ja, das sagst du mir. Quatsch. Und dann einen Wochenende stehst du draußen und das war weg. Und da denke ich mir auch, ja, da habe ich auch die Welt jetzt ein bisschen, ich habe das Vertrauen in die Welt verloren, weil ich dachte, ich dachte mir Köln, hier passiert sowas nicht, aber ich glaube doch die ganze Zeit, man hört halt von Bekannten, dass mal ein Fahrer geklaut wurde, aber es ist noch nie einem selber passiert, das macht schon, ich habe jetzt echt so ein bisschen das Gefühl, ich bin nicht mehr so sicher. Aber angenommen, bei dir wird eingebrochen, wärst du dann lieber zu Hause, während es passiert, oder nicht zu Hause, während es passiert?
Ich wäre lieber nicht zu Hause, während es passiert.
Nicht zu Hause, ne?
Ja.
Also es ist doch gar nicht so...
Ja, wie unangenehm, in dem dann...
Mega, also ich dachte mir...
Erst mal Kaffee anbieten. Als der Kommentar kam von wegen, ja, mach deine Rollladen nicht zu, sonst wird dir eingebrochen, dachte ich mir, in dem Moment waren meine Rollladen zu und ich war zu Hause. Dann dachte ich mir, wenn jetzt jemand so an der Tür nuckelt, sagt man dann, hier ist besetzt, hier ist jemand, ja, danke, macht man dann so Lärm den Zimmerservice-Kram nein, danke, ich brauche noch vor allem, ey, mein Schloss ist mittlerweile komplett hinüber aber mein Schloss ist so, ich glaube verrostet oder vergrösselt und ich muss da unbedingt mal Öl kaufen und ja, ich muss einfach nur Schlüsselöl rein, aber ich vercheck's einfach. Und ich muss wirklich jedes Mal mehr oder weniger mein Schloss knacken, um ins Haus zu kommen. Ich muss den Schlüssel, ich kann meinen Schlüssel nicht mehr ins Schloss stecken. Ich setz ihn an, wackel dann damit und führe gleichzeitig Druck da aus, so dass er sich so rein vibriert, weil ich kann ihn nicht straight reinstecken, weil es ist zu verkeilt und verklumpt.
Und wenn er drinsteckt, muss ich auch vibrierend ihn drehen.
Es sieht jedes Mal, wenn ich bei mir zu Hause den Schlüssel aufmache, es sieht so aus, als würde ich einbrechen.
Aber ich wohne hier und ich meine, sollte, also jetzt mal hoffnungsvoll, sollte ich jemals irgendjemanden mit nach Hause nehmen,
so zu dir oder zu mir, es ist der unsäherr unserigste Eindruck überhaupt, an der Tür zu stehen. Man küsst sich noch vielleicht und dann, warte, ich mache uns kurz auf und dann alles wackelt an dir. Und dann sie so, bist du dir sicher, dass du hier wohnst? Ja, ja, ja, Sekunde, man muss sich so gegen die Tür stemmen und gleichzeitig Druck ausüben. Ja, Tür ist offen. Türen sind auch noch nicht optimal, glaube ich.
Nee, Türen...
Weil unscheinlich jede Tür hat...
Das hat 200 Jahre dasselbe.
Hat eine Eigenart.
Also jede Tür muss man entweder...
Ja, ist immer so, nee, muss sie hochschieben.
Nee, muss sie gegenstemmen.
Nee, muss sie leichter drehen.
Nee, die muss sie nach rechts aufmachen.
Leute, lassen Sie mal die Tür nullen.
Warte, Top 5 dysfunktionale Türen?
Ich sage, Platz 5, die Tür, die ein bisschen zu hoch steht, mit einer Kante unten. Top 4 sind die Türen, wo man den Schlüssel aus irgendeinem Grund in die entgegensetzte Richtung drehen muss. Ja. Autos haben das häufig. Seltsam. Platz drei der dysfunktionalen Türen, Türen, die zu leicht sind und wo man das Gewicht nicht gut handeln kann, die man entweder zu schnell aufmacht, weil man denkt, die Tür ist schwerer, als sie ist, oder wenn man sie zumacht, man sie automatisch zuschlägt, ohne dass man es will. Das sind meine zwei, auch meine Bürotür neuerdings, ich bin wieder umgezogen in ein neues Büro, ich jetzt bis jetzt ständig, und jetzt hat die Tür, die macht man leicht zu und die schlägt zu. Weshalb immer der ganze Raum zusammenzuckt und man anguckt und sagt, was ist dein Problem? Leute, macht's gut, schönes Wochenende, wamm! Ja, fick dich auch, man ist sofort passiv-aggressiv. Platz zwei? Das war mein Platz zwei. Okay, dann Platz eins der dysfunktionalen Türen, Türen, die nur zu so einem Viertel aufgehen, weil sie so in den Boden kratzen und man geht zu voller Elan die Tür auf und es bleibt gerade so bei Teppichböden und man weiß nicht, was man machen soll, sondern man die dann, also gibt es eine Hürde, die zu überwinden ist oder ist es einfach eine Steigung, die immer schlimmer wird?
Furchtbar, man weiß auch nicht, kämpft man dagegen an oder muss man sich so durchzwängen. Das wäre ja mein Platz acht gewesen, aber gut. Was wäre dein Platz eins der dysfunktionalen Türen? Ähm, dann doch die Autotür, die nach oben auf geht. Haben wir alle schon erlebt. Ich sag euch, ohne Scheiss, es ist nervig. Ich dachte, gut angelegtes Netflix Money. Nein, es nervt primär. Auch Glastüren sind nicht meins. Glastüren. Ich verstehe Glastüren auch nicht. Warum muss man durch Türen durchgucken? Ja, irgendwie damit das Büro ist, auf Bürogramm, damit es ein bisschen räumlicher aussieht, irgendwie man sieht, die Leute arbeiten nicht, damit es streng durchreguliert sein kann. Aber niemand außer der Typ, der die installiert, will doch diese Glastür haben. Niemand. Du willst ja beobachtet. Türen haben nicht gläsern zu sein, aber da nehme ich mich ein bisschen aus dem Fenster. Was hältst du von Türen, die so ein kleines Fenster drin haben, vielleicht milchig? Unentschlossen. Ja? Ja, bin ich ein Fenster oder ein bisschen eine Tür? Bin ich Fenster, bin ich Tür, bin ich Glastür, bin ich unentschlossen. Ja. Das ist so, nee, finde ich gut. Kommen wir zu den Top 5 Raumtrennern ein. Also diese, was ich nie verstanden habe, sind diese Perlenketten. Diese Tür, aber keine Tür. Das Haus mit meinem Freund hatte das, Elternhaus mit meinem Freund, da war ich ab und zu. Und ich wusste nie, wie man da durchgeht. Ist es dann so wie so ein, schwingt man das so schwungvoll auf oder? Aber du kannst es auch nicht, du kannst dir vornehmen, gerne, naiverweise kannst du dir vornehmen, da einen coolen Auftritt hinzulegen. Es ist immer Struggle, es ist immer, hängt Perlen oder diese Muscheln teilweise bleiben dann in deinen Haaren hängen. Es ist immer Struggle, es ist nie souverän. Man kann nicht souverän durch diese Dinger gehen. Es ist immer viel Geräusch, viel Lärm, eine Strähne bleibt immer genau zwischen Auge und Nase hängen oder so. Meine Brille ist immer weg danach. Also ich bin ein anderer Mensch. Frisur zerstört. Ich habe auch so einen Kostümwechsel, wenn ich da durchgehe. Das ist das Gegenteil von Mini-Playback-Show. Du kommst schön rein und kommst hässlich durch. Und es ist so, ich weiß noch, das als erstes Mal, als ich das gesehen habe und ich wusste nicht, wie man da durchgeht und ich bin einfach, hab die Arme angelegt an meinen Körper und bin einfach schnurstracks durchgelaufen und hab so alle Ketten einmal über meinen Körper ziehen lassen und bin einfach so durch die Waschstrasse. Die Waschstrasse, ja. Einfach einmal komplett durchgelaufen, weil wenn du noch niemanden gesehen hast, wie man da durchgeht, deswegen glaube ich, sind wir heute souveräner, weil wir mehr Medien konsumieren, Vines, Tweets, Instagram-Stories.
Du meinst, wir sind der Welt ausgesetzt, egal. Naja, ich glaube, wir haben alles schon mal gesehen. Also angenommen, du kommst in Saloon, du weisst, wie du durch die Tür gehst. Ja, angenommen Zeitmaschine, du bist im Mittelalter, du weisst alles, du weißt, wie man auf dem Pferd aufsteigt, hast du in hundert Filmen gesehen, gut, ob du es dann schaffst, weißt du nicht, aber du hast alles schon mal gesehen.
Wohingegen, wenn du in der Renaissance aufwächst, du hast keinen Plan von gar nichts, du bist in einem anderen Land und da ist ein Kamel und da ist ein Kamel und da ist ein, bitte, was ist hier los?
Du kennst ein einziges Lied, andauernd hast ein Ohrwurm von diesem ein einziges Lied.
Dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, wie geht's weiter? Ich hab's leider nur bis dahin gehört. Dann weiss ich auch nicht weiter. Zum Kotzen, ey, es ist furchtbar. Stell dir mal vor, du hast noch nie in deinem Leben Kamel gesehen und siehst einen Kamel. Du denkst, da wollte ich mich verarschen. Ja, aber du kennst einen Dromedar und plötzlich sieht es einfach aus wie ein Ränderfehler, wie so ein Augenproblem. Du kennst das Tier, ist aber eins noch mehr hinten dran. Es gab mal irgendwie so eine Übersicht von potthässlichen Tieren im Mittelalter-Gemälden, also die auch wirklich realistisch gemalt sind, also wirklich dann irgendwie so ein Fürst oder so realistisch. Und der Fürst hat wahrscheinlich gesagt so, Alter, mal doch mal neben mich so einen Löwen.
Du hast schon mal einen Löwen gesehen, oder? Ja, klar, habe ich schon mal einen, bitte, Friedrich, habe ich schon mal einen Löwen gesehen. Mal doch einfach, so neben mir liegt so ein Löwen, mach den mal so richtig, gib den mal so lange. Ich mal den Löwen direkt neben dich. Den Löwen? Löwen, direkt neben dich, sorry. Und gib dem mal so richtig lange Zähne. Die hat er ja auch. Die hat ja auch lange Zähne. Ja, natürlich. Schlauchige, lange Zähne. Ja, natürlich. Aber es ist auch die Frage, wie lang die Zähne sind. Ja, einfach so normal lang. Okay, aber du willst schon... Einfach so hier neben mich, da nehme ich den Fuss so hoch und dann kannst du da in dem Bereich einfach so denwen malen. Genau, aber da musst du deine Füße ja schon, also das hat dich nicht verdeckt. Genau, guck halt, wie viel Platz du brauchst und so. Das ist ja schon ein riesiges Tier, also das hat dich nicht verdeckt. Naja, die haben ja auch dann und diese, aber... Also nicht so gross wie ein Pferd. Nee, ne, nee. Aber naja, ich habe auch erst einmal einen Löwen. Also schon mit den seitlichen. Also guck halt, dass die seitlichen halt so ein bisschen, also auf beiden Seiten wäre haltpektivisch schwer. Perspektivisch päpstlich schwer. Meine Frau sagt mir immer, Johann, du hast ein Stotterproblem, begrenzt deine Sprache. Ich habe mich für ein päpstliches Perspektivenproblem entschieden, beide Seiten gleichzeitig zu malen. Also, sorry, wenn jemand, der stottert, kann ich von diesen Wortkonstruktionen nur abraten. Gut, das war ein Fehler, da habe ich mich ein bisschen verrannt. Gut, ich male beide Seiten bestenfalls. Genau, und die grossen Ohren würde ich einfach weglassen. Wieso? Halt normalgrund. Ja, ja, normale Ohren. Die lasse ich weg.
Ich habe mal einen Löwen gesehen, der hat eine grosse Ohren.
Genau, Löwen.
Einen Löwen gesehen, der hat eine grosse Ohren. Gut.
Wie lange dauert das so ein Bild zu machen? Wie lange muss es jetzt hier so... Drei Jahre.
Drei Jahre? Ja.
Ich habe nur eineinhalb Jahre zu leben, ich bin vierzehn.
Dafür hast du dich aber gut gehalten.
Ne, ich finde, also mir wurde immer gesagt, ab zwölf geht's bergab. Müssen wir reden während den drei Jahren, oder ist es so? Nee, nee, nee, nee. Ist wie sie wollen, die meisten wollen reden, aber viele schweigen auch viel. Die meisten sterben, während ich sie male. Die Augen bitte dringend offen lassen. Ja, ja, ja. Sie haben die Augen zu.
Haben Sie es mitbekommen von dieser Fürstin?
Nee.
Die hat ja jetzt hier wieder neue Pariser Mode.
Ich habe mir auch gedacht, ob ich jetzt auch wieder neue ...
Wisst ihr was, wir lassen das mal einfach meinen Vater und mach den Bart weg. Gut, alles klar. Ciao, gut, ciao, ich muss einen Krieg machen. Herein. Wir haben noch keine Tür klingen, deswegen muss mein Prato. Päpstlicher Perspektiven, Prato. Prappadopoulos. Ich denke mir, diese Gemälde damals, war das schon, war dasFotototermin damals oder nicht? Ja, ich weiß es nicht. Ich glaube, es ist sehr schwer zu sagen, wie solche Leute überhaupt aussahen, weil natürlich haben die gesagt, mach ich mir mal ein bisschen schlanker. Und es gibt ja Porträts von dicken Menschen, wo du denkst, waren die noch dicker? Ja, wahrscheinlich schon. Oder haben die gesagt, mach ich mir mal so richtig schön so. Wobei, dann es auch, es ist schön als Ideal, damals auch ein bisschen stämmiger ist, war das nicht hot, wenn man ein bisschen dicker war. Aber gab es da auch so eine Abnahme, also der Künstler malt es und der Fürst geht da nochmal drüber oder so, ja ne mach die beiden nochmal ein bisschen länger. Nein, mach mal Jakarta-Filter drüber. Schön Jakarta. Schön Filter.
Das war eine Instagram-Referenz, die hast du nicht verstanden.
Ach so, ich wusste nicht, ich war
zwischen Mittelalter und Instagram gefangen.
Da haben wir wieder die zwei Welten, die zusammen
zusammenclashen. So entsteht
Comedia! Oder peinliche
Stille. La Bella Comedia!
Oder La peinliche Stille.
Ach ja, ich übrigens auch noch mal vielen Dank für eure ganzen Tipps, ich habe vor einigen Wochen gefragt, wie man Pfandlos werden kann, weil ich habe sehr viel Pfand angesammelt und ich habe sehr viele Nachrichten erreicht, wie man das machen kann, nämlich bei Pfandgeben, eine App, die in der Theorie und da kommen wir jetzt gleich danach zu, in der Theorie toll ist, Pfandgeben, eine App, die in der Theorie, und da kommen wir jetzt gleich dann auch zu, in der Theorie toll ist. Pfandgeben an Obdachlose, an Bedürftige. Das ist eine App, ein bisschen wie Tinder, ehrlich gesagt, aufgebaut. Und dann sagst du, wie viel Pfand du hast zu Hause. Ich habe angeklickt, kistenweise Pfand. Kannst auswählen, wenig, mittel, viel. Und dann werden dir die verschiedenen Leute vorgeschlagen. Dann steht steht da einfach nur Günther und darunter steht eine Nummer, eine Handynummer. Mit Foto von Günther? Nein, kein Foto. So weit ist es dann doch nicht. Aber es ist eine Nummer drunter, dann klickst du die an und dann kannst du Günther anrufen und sagen, wie viel Pfand du hast und wann er abholen kommen kann. Toll. Also von der Idee her toll. Dann kommen Leute vorbei, die das Geld bitter n nötig haben und du bist dein Fund los. So, win-win. Aber leider, also muss man sagen, diese App funktioniert nicht, weil die meisten Leute, die die Nummern hinterlassen haben, sind offensichtlich verarscht worden von Freunden. Erstens, erstens, zweitens, Sind das nicht die Leute, denen du Fund geben willst? Es ist halt so die Upper Class der Obdachlosen, weil Voraussetzung dafür ist ja, dass sie ein Handy haben. Es sind weirde Obdachlosen, ich weiß nicht, es sind meistens auch keine Obdachlosen, sondern Pflegebedürftige. Die sind dir nicht obdachlos genug. Aber ja, die sind mir zu wenig Obdachlosen. Die könnten ruhig ein bisschen erbärmlicher sein. Die könnten weniger Obdach haben, meiner Meinung nach, ehrlich gesagt. Weil denen, denen man das dann dann gibt, die haben ein Auto und holen das dann ab. Aber die haben ein Auto. Und sie haben ein Handy, wenn die seine Hände haben. Und sie haben ein Handy, also das Und also die meisten, also das ist folgendermaßen geht man dann vor, ich dachte, okay, cool, ich rufe die erste Nummer an, passt schon. Nein, du rufst die erste Nummer an, geht keiner dran. Du rufst die zweite Nummer an, geht keiner dran. Dritte Nummer an, jemand geht besoffen dran und legt wütend auf. Vierte, ja, da haben mich irgendwelche Freunde angemeldet, um mich zu verarschen. Fünfte, welche App ist das? Fund geben, nie gehört. Die meisten haben nie von der App gehört oder vergessen, dass sie existiert. Dann hast du, ich habe irgendwann ungelogen, wirklich, ohne Scheiß, 40 Nummern angerufen. Von denen sind 30 nicht rangegangen, der Rest war hochgradig verwirrt. Und dann kommen so weirde Stunden, weil plötzlich gehen, machen die ihr Handy wieder an oder sowas oder keine Ahnung oder entdecken, dass der Anruf kam. Und dann wirst du für drei Tage lang zurückgerufen von Nummern, die du nicht kennst, von Leuten, die sehr unfreundlich dich anschreien, weil sie betrunken sind oder so oder weil sie nicht der App gehört haben, oder schreiben wütend WhatsApp-Nachrichten oder schreien die auf die Mailbox, also die seltsamsten, krudesten Nachrichten bekommen, das ist eine ganz seltsame Erfahrung. Und dann habe ich nach Tagen der Recherche plötzlich jemanden gefunden, der von der App wusste, von der Existenz, und dann Bock hatte, meinen Pfand abzuholen. Aber es habe mich so anstrengend wahrgenommen, dass ich kurz davor war, diese selbstlose Geste zurückzunehmen, einfach das Pfand wegzubringen. Ja, es ist nicht leicht, ein guter Mensch zu sein, Stefan. Es ist nicht leicht, ein guter Mensch zu sein, ja. Und ich bin heute auch, mir ist heute auch ein, sag ich mal, Obdachloser weitestgehend entgegengekommen. Und weißt du, was der getragen hat? Fullblown Obdachloser? Ah, ich sag mal so, vielleicht noch nicht ganz unten. Und weißt du, was der getragen hat? Nein. Ein Vorderfußentlastungsschub. Nein. Und ihr habt sofort eine Ebene gehabt. Und ich habe ihn angeguckt, Augenkontakt, ich gucke seinen Fuss an. Fusskontakt? Und dann gucke ich meinen Fuss an und er guckt meinen Fuss an und so. Hat er gelacht? Lacht mich an. Aus. Nee, aber so, ah ja, du bist auch einer. Ich dachte mir, ich habe mit diesem Menschen wahrscheinlich fast nichts gemeinsam. So, der ist 60 Jahre alt, keine Ahnung, was der durchgemacht hat. Aber sehr entlastete Vorderfüsse. Extrem entlastete Vorderfüsse, keine Ahnung wie der das bekommen hat und so, aber das hat uns verbunden. So beide, wir sind auf, in dem Moment waren wir kurz auf diesem Niveau zumindest gleich und ich dachte mir, ah, man grüsst sich dann auch so, ja, wenn du ein Vorderfuss Entlastungss-Träger, einfach kurz so ein Gut Fuss. Gut Fuss. Haben wir uns auch viele Nachrichten bekommen, du kannst ihn behalten. Ja, habe ich auch mitbekommen. Und es gibt ihn nur von einer Seite. Ich darf ihn behalten und wäre natürlich super blöd, wenn ich mir dann auch den linken Zeh brechen würde und dann brauche ich nochmal einen linken. Na, hast aber beide auf jeden Fall der Fälle. Aber mir hat das auch mal passiert, mich hat ein Obdachlose angesprochen, er kam an, es kam einfach ein, muss man sagen, recht attraktiver Mann, so Mitte 50, einfach so ein gutaussehender Mitte-fünfzig-Jähriger kam an mit einer sehr schönen Lederjacke und hat gesagt, ob ich Geld hätte für ihn. und dann war ich auch mit einem Kumpel unterwegs und der hat nur gesagt, sie haben aber eine schöne Jacke an und ichke an. Und ich dachte mir auch ja. Und ich war kurz davor, ihm den Tipp zu geben, er hat eine sehr schöne Lederjacke angehabt und hat auch gesagt, ihr könnt die Lederjacke haben, ich mache einfach Geld. So als Spaß mehr oder weniger. Aber ich dachte mir, du siehst zu gut gekleidet aus. Du darfst, als Obdloser, darfst du nicht eine Lederjacke haben.
Ich glaube doch.
Du darfst als Obdachloser, du hast einen gewissen Dresscode, ein gewisses Klischee, ein gewisses Dresscode-Klischee zu bedienen, sonst hast du keinen Erfolg als Obdachloser. Ich glaube, wenn du nicht wie ein Obdachloser direkt aussiehst, hast du die bessere Möglichkeit, überhaupt mal ins Gespräch zu kommen.
Und jemand, mit dem man überhaupt schon redet, hat man eine viel höhere Chance, auch Geld zu bekommen. Weil wenn jetzt wirklich jemand, der offensichtlich von weitem obdachlos ist, dann fängst du gar kein Gespräch an, sondern winkst direkt ab und sagst nein. Aber es ist Gespräch dann ... Wohingegen, wenn jemand sagt, entschuldigen Sie, und du denkst, ah, okay, Uhrzeit, will ein Foto mit mir, was auch immer, und dann sagt er, hast du einen Euro? Aber es ist viel schwerer Nein zu sagen. Ich glaube, so mir würde man, angenommen, ich würde stehen irgendwo in einer Eisdiele und so, und dann gucke ich mich um, oh, Popmonet vergessen.
Und ich drehe mich so um und sage, ach, könnten Sie mir vielleicht einen Euro leihen oder geben? Ja. Glaubst du, man würde mir eher einen Euro geben als ein Obdachlosen auf der Straße? Ich glaube nicht. Doch, auf jeden Fall. Auf jeden Fall. Weird, ne? Mir ist auch noch nicht klar geworden, so, es ist kein wirklich deeper Gedanke, aber es ist schon spannend, dass Reichtum nur ist, also Reich Donald Trump ist hochverschuldet, der Staat Deutschland ist hochverschuldet, mittlerweile aber auch nicht mehr so, aber USA haben auch diese krasse Schuldenuhe. Hoch verschuldet, aber es gilt trotzdem als eines der reichsten Länder mit einem der höchsten Lebensstandards der Welt. Und das Spannende ist ja, dass nur bei Banken denen zutrauen, Erfolg zu haben, Geld zu machen. Auch Donald Trump lebt ja das Leben eines Reichen, nicht nur weil er Präsident ist, abgesehen davon. Er lebt das Leben eines, er hat einen sehr hohen Lebensstandard, ist aber sehr hoch verschuldet, er hat unterm Strich weniger Geld als ich. Aber er hat halt sehr viele Menschen, die an ihn glauben, die auf ihn setzen. Er ist einfach ein schnelles Pferd im Stall in deren Augen. Könnt er nicht seinen Turm verkaufen oder so? Also hat er nicht Materielle Mütter oder so? Ich weiß aber nicht, ob er nicht trotzdem noch Schulden hat. Das würde man doch auch einrechnen. Naja, jedenfalls ist mir nochmal klar geworden, es geht nicht darum, wie viel man hat. Das ist ja auch als Metapher, kann man das ja benutzen. Es geht nicht darum, wie viel du hast, sondern eher, was du ausstrahlst, sodass Leute in dich vertrauen.
Also du bist das wert, was Leute
bereit sind, auf dich zu setzen.
Das ist dein Wert.
Nicht das, was du am Konto hast,
Flotin. Ja, nee, das ist mir
durchaus... Nee, weil du hast schon wieder deine Bank-Account-Checks,
Sparkassen-App.
Nee, was du
ausstrahlst, was Leute auf dich setzen. Das heißt, nächstes Mal beim Bäcker. Ich habe zwei Körner Euro dabei, aber... Kann man Schulden machen bei Bäckern? Ich weiß nicht. Ich weiß nicht, man kann so viel, glaube ich. Ich glaube, wir leben beide noch nicht lange genug in dieser Welt, um zu wissen, was man alles machen kann. Ich glaube, es ist auch in den letzten zehn Lebensjahren, kriegt man nochmal so viel mit. So Endgame-mäßig. Was wir alles hätten machen können. Das kann man machen? Ja, kann es machen. Man kann im Supermarkt einfach zu einer geschlossenen Kasse hingehen, seine Waren dahin legen und dann müssen die die Kasse aufmachen? Ja. Warum hat mir das niemand vor 50 Jahren gesagt? Ja, kann es machen machen, einfach aufs Band schmeissen. Du kannst im Supermarkt Dinge essen und dann die Verpackung bezahlen und es ist völlig legal? Ja. Wie ja? Ja, kannst du einfach essen, solange du bezahlst, ist ja okay. Die Welt ist entspannt und irgendwann so, du merkst, dass die Welt ein anderer ist als die, die wieder immer... Man darf in parkende Autos einsteigen und mit denen fahren, solange man sie da wieder hinstellt, wo man sie abgeholt hat? Ja, ist jetzt nicht mehr, nicht so viel gegen zu sagen, aber wie willst du das Auto denn aufmachen? Wenn es offen ist. Ja, ja, ja, klar. Ich darf in fremden Wohnungen schlafen, wenn es nur niemand merkt? Ja, jetzt langsam kommen wir in so eine Grauzone rein, muss ich dann auch sagen. Es gibt Leute, die zwei Paar Socken tragen? Ja, gibt's, aber es ist auch die Frage, was ist es? Ich muss auch dringend los, dringend los. Hm? Nee. Ich dachte nur. Krass. Oma, das ist wieder anstrengend heute mit dir ein bisschen. Lass mich dir noch ein Rat mit auf den Weg geben. Ja. Im Auto. Ja? Ja. Es gibt noch einen geheimen weiteren Gang. Den Rückückwärtsgeheim? Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee. Du musst rückwärts eins, rückwärts eins, rückwärts zwei und dann durchdrücken. Und dann Motherload und dann kriegst du sehr viel Geld. Und dann hast du Jackpot und dann hast du unendlich Bergekauen. Und wenn du dann
drei Siebener hast im Handschuhfach,
dann bist du reich.
Manchmal war das BTF Sommerfest und ich habe mich sehr lange
mit Sophie Passmann unterhalten.
Eigentlich nur über die Sims.
Das war eigentlich mein ganzer Abend war das Gespräch
über die Sims. Weil mir aufgefallen ist,
also Sophie und ich haben
gemeinsam, dass wir, also gab es
dann eine Kampagne, die man spielen musste? Ja, schon auch. Gewisse Challenges und so. Naja, jedenfalls nicht sterben, ist ja prima das Ziel.
Aber ich habe mir schon Mühe gegeben, die Häuser schön einzurichten und so und habe auch versucht, irgendwie keine Ahnung, einen coolen Stil zu haben und habe Häuser verschieden
ein... wollte ich auch möglich ein realistisches Haus ab und zu bauen.
Und dann irgendwann fällt dir auf, dann hast du versucht, das realistische Haus zu bauen
und dann hast du dieses Mausrad, der damals noch gehabt hat, das grosse, laute Mausrad, und scrollst zurück und zooms raus und merkst kein Dach. Es war immer das Ding, kein Dach. Ja, stimmt. Einfach, ich hab monatelang drangesessen, versucht ein realistisches Haus zu bauen, irgendwann warstnsinnig stolz auf diese Details, dann scrollst du zurück und merkst, kein Dach drauf.
Und wenn man ein Dach drauf macht, sieht es immer so lächerlich aus, weil das Haus ja immer eine riesen Grundfläche hat.
Ja, ja.
Und dann kannst du halt nur diese Spitzdächer drauf bauen und dann scrollst du raus und alle Häuser nebenan sehen normal aus.
Und dein Dach ist so riesig und die Kuppel ist so gross wie diese Weltstadt Germania-Entwürfe von Hitler, wo so Wolken sich bilden würden, weil es die grösste Kuppel der Welt wäre. So was anscheinend. Immer wahnsinnig unrealistisch. Dein Haus ist immer verpixelt und das von den Nachbarn ist immer so schön. Ja, ich habe mir irgendwann selber Challenges auch gegeben bei Sims und eine Challenge war immer, wie weit kommt man mit nur einem Stück Wand. Ich war ein Kind, keine Erwachsenen, ich hatte ein Stück Wand, auf der einen Seite ist eine Toilette, auf der anderen Seite ist ein Telefon an der Wand, mit dem Telefon kann man sich Essen bestellen, das kann man essen und auf der Wiese steht eine Staffelei, damit malt man Bilder, die verkauft man und von dem Geld kann man sich Pizza bestellen. Und das war alles. Ich habe versucht, wie wenig kann man haben, um das Spiel noch zu spielen. Eigentlich aber ich finde es total lustig, weil ich behaupte ein bisschen, dass du so lebst, also nicht ganz so krass, aber ich glaube, du machst das Mindeste an Kunst Staffelei um dir mit dem Telefon, was du dafür leisten kannst. Mit dem einen Stück Wand. Du hast, deine Wohnung ist sehr minimalistisch eingerichtet, sehr spartanisch. Du bist, das ist für mich ein Stück Wand, ehrlich gesagt. Ein Stück Wand. Ja, genau, mit dem nötigsten. Keine Tapete. Das ist das nötigste. Ja. Ja, und du verkaufst deine Kunst, Podcast oder Rocket Beans, um damit zumindest Essen kaufen zu können. Genau. Und du hast ein Klo. Ja, ja. Dusche? Brauche ich nicht. Glaubst du manchmal wirklich nicht nur selbst? Weil ich habe auch, also jetzt können wir die alte Trube vielkauf Stefan wieder aufmachen, aber ich glaube schon, dass ich da eher in Richtung Messi wohne, unterwegs war mit den Zims. Immer kaufen, kaufen, kaufen. Das war ja oft so das Problem, dass dein Haus zu gross war. Dann hattest du eine Küche, ein Bad, ein Hobbyzimmer und dann hattest du noch vier weitere Zimmer.
Und ultralange Wege, also zwischen, also zwischen, von aufs Klo gehen, da ist der Sim schon mal ein paar Jahre älter geworden.
Und dann denkst du dir, jetzt habe ich noch vier Zimmer. Was mache ich denn damit da hinweilen? Ich habe immer Häuser nur im ersten Stock gebaut. Ganz viele Säulen und obendrauf erster Stock das Gebäude und eine Treppe hoch in den ersten Stock. Man musste erst die Treppe hoch und dann, weil ich fand Bäumeise immer so cool, da dachte ich mir so ein großes Haus auf Stelze. Und dann kommen Nachbarn zu Besuch, ja oft, die auch, muss man sagen, Sims-Nachbarn, oh mein Gott, ich würde also soziale Tode sterben, wenn das echte Nachbarn wären, die einfach schnurstrackst, vor allem ziehst du ein in diese Nachbarschaft und die gehen, bevor sie dich begrüssen, kommen sie hinten durch die Terrasse rein und gehen erstmal in den Kühlschrank. Und ich könnte dich immer schon nicht leiden. Da war ich schon unten durch bei mir und dann will das Spiel ja, dass man sich mit ihnen anfreundet und so, aber ich als Mensch dachte, das kann kann ja nicht wahr. Das ist ja ... Ich bin nicht so eine Zeit der Tode gestorben. Die gehen bei sich aus der Tür raus und nehmen dann den kürzesten Weg von ihrer Haustür zu deinem Kühlschrank. Zu deinem Kühlschrank. Zipp, hier durch. Und dann gibt's ja auch dieses ... Ohne Verabschieden, tschau. Und dann gibt's ja auch dieses den Gast nach Hause schicken, ne, so wenn man keinen Bock mehr auf den hat, kann man ausweilen, den Gast wegschicken. Und wenn man das macht, dann lungern die immer noch eine Zeit lang aus auf dem Garten. Ja, weil sie nicht wissen, wo es rausgeht. Also ich muss auch schon langsam ins Bett, ciao. Um bei den sozialen Minusen nachzuurteilen, war das eher ein Geh jetzt bitte. Ja, das war eher ein Geh jetzt bitte und dann lungern die so oben auf dem Gehsteig vor deiner Wohnung. Die strafazieren so ein bisschen. Die ist einfach, hau ab, Alter. Oder machst du so Experimente wie, erster Stock ist nur Säulen, erster Stock ist eine Wand und ein Klo und ein Telefon und dann kommen die hoch und dann siehst du an den Sprechblasen, wor, worüber sie reden. Und ich fand es immer so lustig, dass das kein Thema war. Die offensichtlichsten Dinge waren kein Thema. Nee, dann war erst mal Fussball. Ja, mein Ehemann verbrennt gerade in der Küche, ist tot. Aber nee, wir können ruhig über Fussball und Blumen reden. Kein Problem. Und dann waren auch teilweise so random Gegenstände waren dann in den Sprechblasen Thema. Da habe ich dem Sims dann Sim, oder? Ja, ein Sim. Einzel Sim hat man denen so einen Fernseher hingestellt und dann reden die über Fernseher und so. Ehe man hängt im Pool, keine Leiter raus, stirbt. Weirder Welt auf jeden Fall. Das war eine schöne Zeit. Aber cool, dass du dich da schon irgendwie gefunden hast selbst. Ja, ja. Und tolle Musik. Ganz, ganz tolle Musik bei Sims. Keine Arme mehr. Wir können sie ja drunter schneiden. Macht's gut, haut rein, wir wünschen euch eine ganz fantastische Woche. Viel Spaß, es ist mittlerweile sehr spät, wir gehen direkt ins Bett. Wir gehen direkt nachher. Und sehen uns nächste Woche wieder, wenn es wieder heisst. Herzlich willkommen beim Ufo, bis dahin macht's gut, tschüss, ich sag tschau und wir heben.
Ja, kann ich mich auch noch irgendwo dazwischen noch verabschieden, in diesem Aneinandersetzigen von Wörtern. Sous-titrage ST' 501 Thank you.